quant à l'Indien russe
relations, je le répète, elles se développent très
avec succès avec confiance et tradition nous
nous apprécions vraiment ce niveau.
relation avec
avec nos amis indiens
la relation est vraiment stratégique
nature, ils s'étendent à l'ensemble
ligne
domaines d'interaction est l'économie
et ici de l'énergie et de la haute
technologie ici ici
complexe militaro-industriel et discours
uniquement sur l'achat et la vente de russe
Bras avec Andy j'en ai déjà parlé
à plusieurs reprises ici, la relation que nous avons est très
profond profond et confiant qui
exprimé dans ce que nous
Cindy avec le seul partenaire probablement
nous allons au développement conjoint et
production y compris en Inde
des zones très modernes et
systèmes d'armes avancés, y compris
y compris la technologie des fusées, mais pas seulement si
autres domaines de notre activité
donc je n'ai aucun doute sur
que les relations indiennes russes
continuera à se développer progressivement
Pour le bien
peuple de l'inde fédération de russie